joining us with reaction in the open
Supreme Court vacancy president Trump's
judicial nominations advisers Leonard
Leo and joining us by phone as president
Trump's attorney Jay Sekulow who by the
way does legal work for me and by the
way has you don't basically represent
everybody once my friend and I paid all
right let's start with your reaction to
this is look this is history
this is generations this is an
opportunity now this is a big deal and
let's go through the philosophy of the
president and making this decision well
look I think Roberto I've litigated
Supreme Court cases in front of Anthony
Kennedy for three decades so and about
80% of the time he ruled in our favor
about 20% of time he did not he was was
always a professional but the fact is
that when I disagree with him where he
disagree with me which is right to do he
suggested with us he's wrong counted a
lot more than mine but at the end of the
day I would say more times than not he
went with us but there was not a
consistent what we would call
conservative philosophy in the mold of
say now justice forces or Antonin Scalia
Justice Alito Justice Thomas and this
the president now has an opportunity to
nominate a justice in that
judicial philosophy that the president
talks about and continues to talk about
a man is putting someone on the court
that has that what I would call an
originalist Supreme Court philosophy or
constitutional philosophy a
constitutional conservative you could
call it a lot of different phrases but
the fact that someone that used the
Constitution by the words that are
written in it you amend the Constitution
through an amendment process not through
judicial Fiat I think that's what you'll
see in a Supreme Court nominee
yeah and literally I think what Jay said
is right on the money he Kennedy did not
have a consistent judicial philosophy
which made him the swing vote I mean you
have for reliable liberal justices on
the court right now what I mean we know
how they're going to vote in 910 99
percent of cases this is important
because there's been at least 25 times
that Anthony Kennedy is
with the four liberal justices on the
court this is a game-changer
what's transformative about this is that
the president's committed to nominating
people to the court who have a very firm
judicial philosophy now people who
understand that the Constitution needs
to be interpreted the way the framers
meant it to be individuals who are
courageous in that interpretive approach
and are not gonna flinch we saw that
Neil Gorsuch and I think if the
president nominates another individual
like Neil Gorsuch what we're gonna see
is widespread public support and I would
say also probably bipartisan support in
the Senate to some extent as we did with
justice Gorsuch Leonard Leo you may have
he may be more optimistic than me I I I
just look at the Democratic Party today
and I I think basically unless you're a
saint and you've never written on the
law at all if you have any judicial
philosophy we know what they want to do
and that's Bork somebody I want to go a
little bit deeper J into the idea this
is important for people to understand
the president does not believe in
judicial activism he believes in
separation of powers he believes in
co-equal branches of government
he doesn't believing believe in citing
far in law people they believe in the
Constitution
he believes that justices should not
legislate for the bench that's for the
legislative body to do well that's right
and here's the you mentioned the foreign
law application I litigate in courts and
other countries I've litigated cases in
the European Court of Human Rights and
and when our force when the Supreme
Court of the United States were to cite
and they do from time to time cite cases
from the European Court of Human Rights
recognizing that many of these
governments that are part of the ECHR as
it's called do not even have
constitutions let alone our Constitution
so I think this whole trend that you've
seen develop over the last 40 years on
this goes way back I mean I've been
doing this for 30 years but this goes
way back the idea that and I think this
is where Leonard is absolutely correct
I'm actually optimistic that it we see
and I am convinced we will see a nominee
in the caliber of Neal bors's that
individual will get bipartisan
support that's because yeah that's
because at the end of the day the
reality is that the president is the one
that nominate its with the advice and
consent of the Senate but the president
gets to make the nomination but last
word we'll give it to you literally off
tonight I'm very confident the
president's going to nominate an
extraordinary individual it'll be a big
fight Shawn as you point out but the
American people stand with us in
appointing a front-runner I think it's
somebody who's being very seriously
considered absolutely thank you both